My one of my dad's favorite
comics was a Stan hope.
He loves Stan Hope I'll never forget.
I did a show with Stan hope in Syracuse
actually in in when my dad was sitting
next to me while we're watching Stan hope
and he leaned over, he was like, man,
the mind on this guy.
It's like one of the brightest,
brightest people I've ever heard in my
life. Dutch get out more. He, well, he's,
he's in a grave now.
He's only getting out was a ghost.
He's probably a drunk ghost at some girl's
house right now because he can't find,
mine was getting ready to film another
special. Yeah, very excited. Watch. Yeah,
it's going to be great. Sandal
was, he's like the, I don't know.
He's like the equalizer when it
comes to what's going on in society.
It just has a way of being like,
boom,
this is what's going on with gun control
and with people being offended by
terminology and words. Here's
why it's ridiculous. Yeah.
He's good like that. Well,
he works. He's a guy that he and
he works on his own schedule.
He decides when to write, when to
perform, when the tour, what to do.
And he was always like,
am I just fucking retire right back at it?
And you're special coming out next
year. He's always, he's always working.
He always working. He has his own lane.
Yeah, he's amazing. I love watching him.
Glad he's out there cause he's just like,
he's basically an older version of the
guy. He was like 20 plus years ago.
It's not changed at all other
than like become more wacky.
Was fucking goofy suits and Jay
let's fucking suits. Every time I see
him, what the fuck? But here's the thing,
like that's one of the things like he
owns the solution can wear the suit if you
wear a goofy suit,
like a really shitty suit like Stan hope
were peach colored suit with ruffles.
He wears loafers.
Like a old man from caddy shack.
He looks like he used to sell cars
20 years ago and kept the outfit.
Frazier Smith's long lost cousin.
He looks like a 12 Toledo
cousin from Toledo sells cars.
He looks like a ghost from the titanic.
He rents out clowns,
shoes, those shoes I button. You're
right. That's his, that's his thing.
That's his look.
No one can do suits and he's been
rocking this look for quite a while now.
Like he used to dress like a
normal person. I mean there was a,
there was always a level of
uh, of eccentric. You have any,
he can replace his
entire wardrobe for $40.
Yeah, I mean you could get that
jacket for $2 and it's amazing.
Then he finds him all that seemed to
be tailored. It's like he gets a fraud,
he takes these things. He takes these
shitty fabrics to like a real high end.
Taylor. And he has them like slim fit it
and he gets them for tens. He finds them.
He doesn't,
he find someone,
me definitely get some nice tailored look
at that shirt, bum jacket, the shirt.
And it's not bombed though. It's all
nice and killing. It's nice and clean.
But I'm saying it looks like a bum
that struck it rich real quick.
Like he got money fast and
didn't know what to do.
So he just bought the same suits,
but cleaner.